une production du studio sfr ni eau sans
filtre le podcast où on parle ce qu'on
veut avec nos invités de ces super
acheter avec moi d'une planche de salut
à gagner un petit message et en
commençant le podcast pour annoncer que
sur le studio est certes notre studio
qu'on possède ensemble de mémoire on a
lancé un nouveau podcast qui s'appelle
elle parle donc sympa de casquettes
animé par léa clermont dion une autre s
activer cette animatrice 30
doctorante donc s entretient à chaque
deux semaines donc c'est un podcast
bihebdomadaire s'entretient avec chaque
deux semaines avec une femme au parcours
qui la motive qui l'inspiré ministre
féministe aussi avec un angle féministe
en fait dans la conversation
et là le premier épisode de ce podcast
cela est avec nul autre que mitsou une
grande femme au québec mitsuki qui est
venu jaser avec les a c'est vraiment une
conversion une conversation extrêmement
inspirante qui nous fait voir un petit
peu
la vie derrière le personnage mitsou
donc on vous invite grandement à aller
vous abonner à toutes les plateformes de
elle parle donc on parle ici de youtube
de balados le spa des forêts partout est
ce que vous écoutez en ce moment le sans
filtre puis en fait si vous écoutez le
sans-fil prend manque vous aimez sur les
podcasts donc à l'échec et ça c'est
vraiment pas de caisse de qualité qu'on
produit sûr je te dire au cfp duquel on
est très fiers sinon on a des
commanditaires pour le propose
aujourd'hui d'un yes premier
commanditaire finances doit mieux c'est
une entreprise qui aide les étudiants
universitaires à optimiser leurs
finances attribue maximum leurs prix et
bourses vraiment pied du terril mes
avantages possibles de financiers en
général c'est gratuit ça se fait à
distance via leur site ce qui peut être
un pyjama chez vous d'inscrire là dessus
puis optimisée des finances moi
personnellement cash à l'université mais
finances c'était un peu floue pour moi
c'est encore un peu flou pour peut dire
grand père flouzat à date ça marche mais
ça ce week-end a dit que c'était moi
j'peux plus j'veux malheureusement puis
étudiant universitaire mais sur les
thèmes inspirés se refinancer au mieux
dans le mois de décembre tout ceux qui
vont s'inscrire et ont fait retirer un
billet pour aller voir un match des
canadiens ses hôtes quand même pop et
très cool enfin que c'est une façon de
maximiser ses finances aussi de ne pas
avoir besoin de payer pour un billet du
match et voilà finances toi mieux et ce
que vous là dessus cette adversité
c'est juste du positif à retirer la
gestion de vos finances
c'est gratuit dans mon parent beaucoup
de temps c'est super facile fait que à
lecce qui se financent toi mieux et
voilà j'ai aimé ça avoir ce ou savoir
que ça existait quand j'étais à
l'université s'arrête ça aurait fait son
bout de chemin pour moi et voilà sinon
cette semaine pour une deuxième semaine
consécutive
écolo fitness monde j'aime le jam de
domme et call of nurses en fin de
semaine j'étais à saint-girons parce que
j'avais à faire là puis dans une pose de
jobs
juste à l'est où un colonel saint jérôme
qui est vraiment pas mon écolo fitness
mais ça m'a permis d'y aller parce que
goethe abonnés la team weakners ça me
donne accès au 79e au québec puis pour
un prix qui est extrêmement raisonnable
dans certains j'aime vous allez payer à
chaque mois ce qu'on paye pour un année
d'abonnement platine chez écolo fitness
il ya tout ce que vous voulez dans le
james tout les équipements que vous
voulez il ya même des circuits 30
minutes pour les gens qui sont pressés
il ya même des cours de vélo en groupe
sur des écrans géants peut choisir les
trainings que vous voulez c'est vraiment
un jam très pertinent ou est-ce qu'il ya
surtout pas de jugement ça c'est
important vous voulez vous remettre en
forme vous savez pas trop comment
commencer à l'est la personne ne vous
jugez vous avez tout le monde va
s'entraîner dans un espèce dans un
environnement convivial
puis avec tout les équipements
nécessaires pour plus d'information on
va mettre le lien dans le podcast ici
donc aller voir ça puis on vous
encourage à vous entraîner en fait
c'était tu l'aidés c'était n'était pas
l'idée c'était pas mal 27 km de course à
pied de 10 de la fin juste débit cette
semaine cette semaine trois ans
commencera aujourd'hui c'est
l'entreprise cocquyt qui est une
entreprise montréalaise qui vous
facilitent la vie avec vos repas dans le
fond comment ça marche
si qui veut commander une bonne j'ai
cédé parmi des repos pour sauver ce tous
les ingrédients sont là pour faire la
recette fait qu'ils aient besoin d'un
con con d'amande demande a besoin d'un
front chaud 7 puis si vous décidez de
faire chez primark cheese ou vega nous
peu importe quoi je le dis ça je ne sais
même pas si jamais les pommes et il ya
plein de délicieuses recettes chaque
semaine où je sais parmi 14 délicieuse
recette pire des options vg parmi ce
qu'a fait donc s'y livrer chez vous ça
vous allait vraiment une grosse charge
mentale d'avoir à planifier vos repos à
aller à l'épicerie chercher ce à
cuisiner c'est vraiment super bien vous
le cuisiner vous même mais tout est là
pour le faire vraiment rapidement et
facilement
moi je fais tout le temps la même ostie
de recettes vraiment langage parce que
j'ai jamais vraiment appris que ce n'est
pas plus c'est une manière de retrouver
le plaisir de cuisiner de bien manger de
manger des choses variées les choses qui
sont bonnes c'est vraiment le fun puis
une digne des meilleures recommandations
qui l'intronisé aussi avoir le plaisir
de manger et cuisiner à la maison d'un
nouveau guide canadien
c'est bien dit on est tous dans le jus
nous tous un mode de vie très chargé
très actif la nutrition c'est souvent
quelque chose qui prend le bord mais
c'est fondamental à une bonne santé et
une bonne équilibre de vie alors qu
quitte on a un code promo pour ceux qui
veulent dans le fond je vous encourage
l'utiliser parce que c'est quand même 50
% de rabais sur les deux premières board
qu'elle allait commander
alors coup quitte quand dévorer pas là
dessus et votre vie sera plus simple est
meilleur exactement puis une des grandes
un des grands désastres de nos jours si
le gaspillage alimentaire picou kit ça
permet d'avoir les quantités exactes
donc lutté un petit peu contre le
gaspillage alimentaire tout à fait sinon
cette semaine sur le sans filtre on a
reçu mon boy mon pdf keven que vos
cheveux pour d afrique du sud qui a
vraiment eu un parcours
particulier spéciale est difficile quand
nature tumultueux rocailleux comme ils
l'aiment le décrire ça a fait comme jean
do québec je pense qu'on voulait le
recevoir surtout oui pour vous parler
des question d'hommes et c'est surtout
il ya vraiment eu une espèce de
mouvement ou de polémique qui quitta les
plus largement que je demande aux dés
toutes les questions de l'intimidation y
avait des candidats qui s'acharnait sur
lui on est revenus là dessus comme qui
voici comment ça l'affecté comment
maintenant six ans par rapport à ceux en
rétrospective un gode très solide très
confiant très grande et très serein ph
le disais tantôt ça fait même pas une
semaine qui est sorti
puis il semble être vraiment bien dans
sa peau pas trop chambouler l'intérieur
pour être trop déséquilibré par tous
ceux s'était pas c'est pas ton côté
exact on a une sortie de rodez qui
complément différent peut-être
intéressant d'entendre son sa
perspective par rapport à sa soeur parce
que effectivement moi je n'ai pas vécu
du tout comme lui le vécu donc c'est
super intéressant d'avoir deux versions
une belle rencontre qui sont requis pour
les curieux des audits dans la mort des
petites infos sur lesquels vous goûté à
l'or yes
si vous écoutez en ce moment et que ce
soit sur youtube son pécule en surpayant
sur youtube sur balles à dos sur spotify
les sonorités un commentaire on le dit à
chaque fois il ya une raison pour
laquelle on dit à chaque fois c'est
parce que c'est ultra important parce
que ça permet en plus de mon mental de
son fils ça permet au moteur propager et
également on a une page piquionne si
vous voulez nous encourager avoir accès
à toutes les podcasts en primeur le
paquet de keven dont la tournée la
veille la diffusion dons qui seront pas
nécessairement primer sur pétrole parce
que parce qu'on les dernières minutes
parce qu'on voulait la voir absolument
le plus près possible de sa sortie de
rodez donc c'est ça qu'on a fait
j'espère que vous allez apprécier la
conversation comme non l'apprécier avec
1go
on sait que le mot alpha et bêta existe
pas beaucoup maintenant le site de
construire les lignes et former second
laisse pas mal au mollet on va se le
dire de suite fait un bon pas de castres
bonne écoute
[Musique]
ça lui même saluer veine accepter quand
on voulait inviter deux mots dit s'est
écrasé en dix ans parce que probablement
la meilleure façon de te rejoindre c'est
surtout à partir du nom complet puis je
me suis dit ah je sais pas combien de
jours j'attends avant qu'ils aillent se
fouler toutes ces billets moucaye et
l'énergie de faire ce que moi quand je
suis sorti je me rappelle j'avais
j'avais tellement de messages qui les
anime écrivait jean ramel what's up
intervenus piges je voyais pas leur
message de répondre à tout le monde non
plus deux comme allemand encore là c'est
vraiment le mal mais ni d'audinet ouais
ouais ouais juste monter un petit peu
dans ma tête avec la poser la question
avant quand on commence mais ça m'embête
oui ça va vraiment vraiment je peux pas
écouter encore un petit peu c'est juste
une semaine pied je bouge la mort puis
de l'autre
mon âge est à peine sorti des valises de
trancher cependant tout comme facteur
c'est la réception au québec était
incroyable
je ressens pas le besoin de rester à la
maison ou jardine cacher ou peu importe
le tout le monde n'apprécie primé mais
dangereux puisque je me soucie je mange
ma cache pas le pire c'est un tout c'est
d'avoir une espèce de vague d'amour
quand tu reviens de comme revoir ton
monde mais aussi le monde que tu qu'à
l'époque sont juste contentés world
mais c'est fou d'après ce témoin c'est
fou le phénomène ouais ont-ils le monde
qui te deviennent potes il vient pas
t'arrêter dans ta face n'arrête pas d'en
rue pour te dire aimanté de la marque à
la piquante et le monde que tu fais
juste les lire sur les réseaux sociaux
écrivent noix les rues mais c'est pas
ils viennent pas de dire sur la facture
c'est juste fou ce jeu était minime
pourcentage croissant tout en le
maintenant négatif tu jouais je vais
bien faire exhorte le dis moi mais ma
boîte de dire je te pète de voir un peu
de dans quelle direction les messages en
ligne aux pigeons n'ai pas vu un seul
d'un connotation négative dit celui qui
sont en colocation négatif c'est envers
les autres candidats que je bâtis sur
facebook selon game ou si c'est plus les
opinions partagées et c'est sûr madame
et david y est maintenant quitterait le
temps d'écrire sait seulement qu'ils
prennent la maîtrise et je dispose
depuis sur 5 c
c'est un cas tu étais quand tu étais là
bas est ce qu est selon toi ce qui a été
montré à télé c'était une bonne
représentation de ton aventure à toi ben
je pense que oui c'est ça qui était -
qu'est-ce que vous avez vus à tv puis
moi qu'est ce que j'ai vécu c'est comme
un peu différent parce que j'avais
vraiment l'impression d'être un punching
bag cgt calmont et ça me met des
bâtonnets groupe iliad est affamé gatti
qui était dit à mon sujet qui était
comme profond débat place de comme je
suis confronté le mans je suis j'ai
décidé de laisser ça l'est parce que
combo
qui jalouse j'avais juste une mauvaise
image des bateaux les candidats s'étant
déplacé le feu dans le fond je les joue
savoir la paix puis on s'attaquait tu
sais moi j'étais arrivé là bas on a une
expérience puis j'avais quand même un
peu visuellement par contre je pensais
pas que j'allais salle est aussi des
cailloux sur ces cas c'est fou mais
ouais je ne suis pas de votre
présentation
c'est sûr que si gérer mais ce qu'est
légumes et on vient me voir en pleine
phase pour me dire des enfants de voir
ce que ça aurait pu comme ça aurait pu
charger aux mondiaux pillon aujourd'hui
mettront à l'édition j'ai pris en
sortant de la maison où s'est rendu le
jeu des comptes a sorti des maisons
j'étais là-bas et puis j'irai plus loin
pensez de tout juste mais tu as vraiment
géré la situation comme un champion
justement le fait d'avoir été autant
malmené par toutes les autres gueules de
garder la tête haute même traité
d'enfant puis cityval afin d'être
clairement tu étais comme le troisième
roue de tout le monde
le couple quatrième union pigeard
c'était le même pige à 15 écouter les
émissions étaient comme j'étais encore
là trop c'est une expérience en faut
pour vous ce pitch est un guerrier faguo
je voulais pas s'il ya eu certainement
match que je les mange à louis ii c'est
comme un gros rhume en émotions étaient
sortis que c'était parti quand même
tu arrives tu à la fête ce serait comme
le sait je commençais ma claque l'heure
de jeu capable si j'ai le dos large
capable d'en prendre mais le ch et
éternuer mais en bout de ligne après
réflexion parce que j'ai parlé avec
l'équipe de production qui ont été
séparées en émoi c'est je me suis jeté
un guerrier participative si je sors je
lisais à lui redonner sa participation
ce que tu as vu à l'image par rapport à
toi si fidèle mais deux teams et ont vu
des choses dans l'émission où que je
sois s'est pas passé de même où souhaite
vraiment tu avais pas vus souvenirs
intimes et ont des comportements
certaines personnes que tu as appris en
le voyant
ben c'est ce que titre les
professionnels de mathieu picard en
particulier je m'attendais pas à ce que
ça soit aussi intenses que ceux qui on
s'entend que plus qu'elle immobilisait
faisant penser plus que tu sais j'en
mettais à plier en métal yamaha tech3
sauvette et à écouter tecteo l'éduction
on a fait du sud à quelques temps on
nageait qui est dans la maison
d'ecrouves exactes m vingt personnes
actives tapas d'autres structures on
était avec campbell oui on était les
trois hommes qui et on écoutait souliers
trou est fait c'est ce que tu vois mon
but on vivait certain malaise personnel
on la regarde en soi mais c'était peu
s'est moins vendu randy droits des
résidents des maisons je m'étais et du
diable on dit c'est fini nous fournissez
je veux pas je vais pas vides parce
quelqu'un on regarde les émissions en
français avec 1 avec un grain de sel on
met de l'eau dans advance on a besoin de
parler on georges mais après ça on n'en
parle plus mouvantes une annexion
on profite du temps l'a fait parce qu'on
sent d'haïti comme j'existais c'est une
expérience incroyable autant aussi belle
à la vive à fond sa rancune pied de ce
poste au travail et l'épisode du split
mais ces trois semaines ne s'était pas
me faire la paix après que ces personnes
doivent vraiment avec celle où ces
montures madore de la main un temps de
roder fait que je savais que la
réconciliation à lesparre pas mal plus
facile qui avec d'autres candidats comme
d'attendre je m'arrête pas vu passer
trois semaines avec un super claude
fauquet
les missions qu'on a présenté yahoo
d'extraire se trouvait le blue est
arrivé puis c'est lydie fourche et puis
moi je le pratique à rien que je
comprends c'est ça il fait de la peine
en bout de ligne ça c'est arrivé on a
joué par la suite la deuxième de la
journée par la suite retourné talent des
jeunes et on ne changera plus de tubes
on a mis un terme à nos bisbilles et
puis on a passé trois semaines
incroyables est 3ème avec notre
coordinateur de coordonnateur c'est cool
ça me rappelle quand qui on attendait la
finale
on était à tremblant dans un chalet pour
l'été et trois coupes finaliste ont été
leurs puis on écoutait les émissions
tout le monde ensemble
je vais à présent mener cette espèce de
conversation là que j'ai lu avec cédric
defrance et rien en fait m
on est des amis pillon on était contre
ou dangereux puis on a essayé de
s'éliminer mais comme la prochaine à
ford
comme si tu es seul jeu munitions jours
au camp contre l'autre
je réside de marquer un but c'est toi tu
es là pour çà fait que fait que c'était
sur des conversations au pipi aussi ce
monde là c'est qu'ils comprennent qu
est-ce que tout véhicule
ouais c'est moi cendres et qui a pas
beaucoup de monde à part adam ou qu'il
pense à de rares puisque ce qu'on avait
passé à travers je peux pas parler un
million de personnes de cette aventure
le nom c'est un jeu au final assez
basses une compétition est ce que moi je
me rappelle quand j'étais sorti le taux
de dollars d'avoirs de l'art d'être
ultra positif par rapport à tout sur moi
je n'en avais quand je suis sorti même
avant de voir les émissions même avant
de voir tout ce qui avait été montré et
puis que j'étais en accord ou non avec 6
avec l'émission je me rappelle que mon
aventure en tant que tel je voyais
beaucoup plus de négatif quand j'étais
collé dessus que positif parce que toi
ce nom par rapport à comment je l'avais
vécu mettons-les les ors interminable a
rien qui sait où un espèce de l'espèce
de caen qui est un petit joueur mode qui
est laissée côté aux parties le tas
comme six jours a rien qui c'est à juste
penser à ces grosses tiges la marre de
tomber à poser des questions sur c'est
quoi les nominations pire at endormir
les danton limité que fermer les yeux
puis juste penser à qui
ça arrive que ce qu'on fait ça ça arrive
la semaine moi ça me rendait fou le pis
j'en ai gardé longtemps même quand je
suis sortie c'est quand qu'ils n'étaient
pas si haute que je voudrais quelqu'un
bouge et andré gide clé c'est ce puits
sais où je n'ai pas le gars qui voulait
parler trop trop de la game est souvent
plus j'avais qu'on était dans un évent
puisqu'on y est on est vraiment rare
fermé on a pas de livre on n'a pas de
musée qu'on appelle moi j'ai juste un
lieu qui cuisinent plus ou moins d'un
avis mais je me suis vraiment un peu sa
cuisine et bien vanter de son adversaire
puis m'entraîner faire la belle pour la
plage mais la piscine des trucs comme ça
fait vendre et que comme ça faisait
juste m'aider à penser à voir si tu
savais qu'avec du mois qui était plus
stratégique que moi fait certaines
choses que je gardais pour moi
maintenant je parlais avec chris c'est
juste parler avec eux je trouve que ce
qui se passe à gène 36 des potiers du
véhicule et beaucoup d'expérience de vie
et c'est pour ça que je voulais un peu
plus à lui 60 fait du bien mais sinon
utilisant un terminal comme si johnny
zotto début on était comme traités comme
des princes les une maison une maison
goût de déficit voulais avoir plus que
la deuxième est longue est arrivé qu
elle ait trouvé le talon le laisserai
semaines le temps qui nous gavent
vraiment d'enea
dans noir béret on savait qui se passe
est affaire de l'aube mais nous on
n'avait aucunement accès c'était
ridicule alors plus que c'est pâques est
ce que les filles parlent qu'est-ce qui
se disent sais pas qu'est-ce que les
autres god is de toi non plus les
équipes qui se forme si je sais moi je
caressais etienne pidoux oui mais
opérées selon ce même pas aux autres
listes recueillent les augures
philippe j'y suis de kokhav erreur en
sortant des maisons la regardant les
émissions en fait je n'avais aucune idée
de qui ressort le sait ce qui se passe
ouais moi je me rappel suite après avoir
écouté le tapis rouge les filles les
premières feuilles se font dire à qui il
ya une deuxième maison fille le l'écran
ferme là on les revoit plus dur est de
l'émission ouais mais moi genre ayant
vécu ce jeu c'est même qu'en ce moment
les filles qui viennent de se faire
annoncer ça ça doit être bannie ils
doivent en être le genre ils doivent
créer des caméras après des comme ça pas
de sens mais quelque chose que tu
laisses grossesse et comme j'ai récente
vous l'avez coupe ddd annonçait comme
inutilement
je peux aussi vous rappeler la fois
clairement s'il est le pitch un mot
politique légal est resté le jeune homme
en janvier de 5 à 7 le crash
je sais pas s'il ya du monde qui disent
la fin d'un monde où je peux qu est ce
que j ou fermer le siège commence à
trouver selon le jeu commence à trouver
solo par as la maman aussi l'annoncé
fait voyager c'est du style lego lego
ils vont dormir et y vont dormir se soit
pas flash pas besoin d'être sale mais où
l'aube hier un autre aussi nous annoncer
une annonce d'activité piet du bon et
c'est la foi de trucs danois de toute
l'information nécessaire de la fae
les deux sont dans l'aude maison puis
j'ai fait je sens aller à l'école il ya
une belle perte de temps ça c'est fait
pour ça
non c'est tout le temps la même recette
c'est comme genre on vous envoie à telle
place puis vous allez faire ça mais
c'est je me rappelle est en fête samedi
justement après j'ai reçu paix avec avec
les beaux débats lippi après survenus
chez nous puis j'avais comme envie de me
replonger au plaza fait que j'ai écouté
l'émission de ma première dette avec
geci dans le cadre de mon émission ou
est ce que c'est on serment en moto
c'est l'annoncé exactement sur le sujet
qui monte en occupe
est ce que ça vous tente de faire la
moto bleue tout le monde dort way ticket
leur permis baissent et vous deux et
puis aussi est ce que dans le fond avec
tout ça est ce que ta relation est ce
que vous avez une relation avec dieu ou
non avec j'ai pas vraiment je pense que
c'est un gars qui quand ils soient
professionnels s'y affairent fait que
c'est sûr que quand il ya des captations
o cotation c'est quand j'y viens
d'essayer quelque chose
les captations il vraiment comme saillie
s'ils saluent les diggers ça va oui ok
pas fait cette annonce après sa jolie
petite gueule
bonne soirée bail mais tu sais quand on
était dans des moments comme ça arrive
des fois qu'ils venaient s'entraîner du
sujet la fin de semaine ou à la cheville
et est aujourd'hui en dehors de
captation bâti on joue un peu avec mes
fallait pour qu'on parle de la game
enfin d'arriver très très très rarement
mais ceux ci étaient quand même très
souvent ceux avec qui je pense que je
serais je pas bien en attendant de les
persuader c'est vraiment un coup mais
plus maintenant
les gueules plus généreux de son temps
et de sa personne que je connaisse
france pas attentionné ou aux gens de
tri à tout le monde pas gentil est-ce
que c'était toujours votre nounou c'est
toujours ouest et ouais
c'était cool wallonie vraiment
impeccable on a tellement une belle
relation ensemble l'autisme à tout les
goûts mais moi le sujet je l'aimais
certain moment est ce que je me prive
j'avais besoin de parler plus à lui que
d'autres gars faites sur night of
hunters et pts puis c est quand même
assez objective mais christie fait un
bon stage absent il sommes vraiment à
112,6 issue père attentionné et pillé
tally copie j'ai vraiment lui qui était
la première fois que j'ai eu une
activité avec ma blonde puis puis c'est
grâce à lui est en fait qu on a eu notre
première vraie conversation qui n'est
pas au tour d'audi alors est ce qu'il ya
comme une captation quitte avec
cendrillon amy puis moi j'étais avec
jessy pi gioi nous surveiller pendant
qu'on qu'on attendait dans le fond puis
on est allé manger avec tout
puis la règle et elle ne parlait pas de
la game baseball mais à rythme la game
c'est parfait jean-louis je veux
rencontrer quelqu'un je vais arrêter
pour toutes les doses et lui était là on
a parlé d'un million la forme c'est là
qu'on a fait est-ce que ce que vous
aviez beaucoup de marocains avec les
autres est-ce que je formule la question
qui aimait tant d'attentes on voyage
avec gênés ferai ce que vous aviez
beaucoup de liberté aux camerounais
qualité tout à fait parie qu'il n'y
avait pas de captation mais c'est ce qui
attire mois puis jhen on avait comme un
certain potentiel
anton potentiel à muro s'ils ont pu
fêter insisté car assez surveillé dans
ce sens qui est comme ça on a fait de la
route on a fait comme ça un choeur de
chant mais sait on sait très belles
barbes basse et on parle d'un code
mais non c'était car assez limité le
dernier souper qu'on a pensé à l'écrit
l'équipe de prod le sait et europe on a
dix fois puis on a eu cependant
tabarouette saison de super pendant deux
trois heures de trappes en agence de
tout et de rien avec tout le monde comme
ça c'était vraiment vraiment cool
c'était qu'il était voyage est sûre il y
avait tué trois personnes
ouais c'était karine
il y avait héliades pire marque dans le
fond ok moi c'est la même que j'ai eu à
londres chicago mais il y a dans le fond
il a partagé sa job avec un autre avec
un orgueil mais moi j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir les trois mois et demi de voyage
semaine caméraman real plus exactement
exactement piger thème entre paix avec
ceux avec ses airs extrêmement dures
elles sont c'est plus le fun c'est
vraiment son coup les oignons une grosse
chimie les trois ensemble et embarque un
peu dans leurs billets dans leur
gameplay c'est en plein ce qui m'attend
si tu compares mon voyage avec jay
encore comparer à celle avec l'odyssée
claudio nous on est en cause et chacun
d'abord fait tilt et markham
selon lui beaucoup plus pin donné pas
mal plus de liberté parce que ça va être
salée pour développer dans de quoi qu'il
ya des vecteurs chambre vous avez plus
de maman juste pour qu'ils saturent on
respecte le haut diplomate cela fait
vraiment
non mais quand j'avais flashé sur elle
je savais qu'on allait passer du bon
temps pour ça c'est surtout la fille qui
parle finalement par de la game plutôt
qu'allemande beach puis on va même pas
sûr puisque je sais que si tu sors les
statistiques maintenant des archives à
mathieu taquin 10% garder qu'est ce
qu'ils disent et des niaiseries 20% qui
parle de claudie puis 70% qui fait juste
par l'idée enfin je pense à vos paniers
à deux minutes
ça a été vraiment toi quand tu es 4 est
sorti tout est conscient de ce que
rapidement tommy à l'affût de commence
avait été perçue ici espèce de pétitions
complexe me jean paul ouin ouin gto toi
j'étais militant de ce film c'est mon
nom comme dit saint mais c'est sûr qu'il
faut que l'on reste transparent puis ils
m'ont foutu telle est le mot qui
s'occupe de nous au club offre qui soit
commun à ces objectifs qu'est ce qui se
passe mais le jeu parce que moi j'étais
un code particulier dans presque toutes
les sports d'eau des rangs du nul mais
quand je rentrais le team à nous on me
dit c'est qu'elle je vois je te dirai
c'est le monde sont avec toi ouais c'est
ce que m'a dit + chicago qui occupent le
plus qui a fait dire se placer comme bt
surtout quelqu'un va-t-il voir la fin
mon parcours qui si je commence
sérieusement à douter
je me disais pourquoi tout le monde est
comme moi j'étais vraiment d'idée avant
vous faites des trucs c'est comme contre
les règles cataldo des vertiges et avec
hamas en 2006 j'avais de quoi déjà le
dixième jeu du passé mais qu'est-ce que
les paroles que j'ai dit le mot pour mot
je pense pas par quatre chemins pour
dire qu'est ce que j'avais à dire
j'avais hâte de voir la réception du
monde face à mon image mais d'où tu
penses que ça je lui dis pas mal remise
entrevu une enfant que j'arrivais ceux
qui montrent un tout petit peu plus
c'était mon intérieur claudie masque au
début quand je rentrais cgra contre les
faits puis claudie première chose qu'un
d'ici à kiev genre tu es un bon jour de
goog ce centre était contré selon
montre-t-il samedi que j'avais avec
toutes les filles de la femme et ma
maison ma tarte aux pommes et ses
proches lundi qu'elle était vraiment le
ghana n'a plus arrêté montréal bonjour
de philippe si j'avais flashé sur tapis
rouge que je teste pas content j'ai
tracé mon fils est un être pour claudie
moi je joue on est à odessa qu'on est là
comme une menace et une menace à
laquelle je monte mon intérieur par
claudie prendrait jusqu'à j'ai sorti le
bidon plongé de la lunetterie city
l'allumette en plus d'être effectué
scarlett est jaloux avec quelqu'un mais
moi je n'ai jamais caché mes intentions
by claude comme étant en état au démène
depuis comme avec des parties génitales
à faire puisqu'il et la mana que moi je
vais procéder puis c'est ce que je dois
faire mais c'est vrai j'ai un peu qu'ils
étaient bien partis à pied vers la main
puis à voir à 11h en françe va donner
cette chance sans jamais trouver de loin
de pouvoir me dévoue à l'émeute on ne
peut plus avoir que l'audi mais bon je
sais vraiment pas si je pense que c'est
vraiment de luxe a commencé la rive
segment une rivalité à sens unique les
wallons du lol ouais ben oui bâtir en
plus souvent quelqu'un perd dans le
monde me dit ward m'at-il dit à la fois
quand il ya chars venus donc là il y
avait pété sacoche ton charme c'est un
acteur dans la la je fais pas confiance
dans la pi il était tellement qui reste
après moi qui saigne à broyer lundi on
s'entend puis quand moi je t'avais l'on
nommé 10e puis je me sens à 100 jusqu'à
six mois j'ai entendu tes la face et
kiki 10e et de six mois justement
pourquoi tu as fait pourquoi tu dis ça
je sais pas mais je m'excuse mais je
m'arrête à pied en passant devant passer
à autre chose mais cela ce que seul le
fait que s'est excusé d'avoir des propos
qu'il ya dix ans vingt mois attendez je
trouve qu'ils font dans l'émission 106
et tabassé sa part une les excuses mais
les actions voleurs vont encore plus toi
pas pire fait depuis hier face aux
experts la répétition
je sais pas comment je sais pas comment
je vois je me réjouis après changement
la première fois je vais voir si je
m'attendais excuses mais c'est l'orgueil
le triste mais c'est fou parce que
justement ce phénomène l'île d'er
d'intimidation aujourd'hui c'est d'unité
c'est devenu gros point que j'écoute et
écoutent la radio canada qui parle de ce
bouquet nadaud sortir vous imposer
tic de com mais recule pas déjà loin qui
s'est elle est loin on la voudrait mais
ça en même temps je trouve quand même
drôle parce que c'est ce qui rend les
actions pour pour rectifier le tir plana
meja des crises sont déjà au voyage
final c'est alex aux prises à partie au
montage mais ton genre couper un peu au
montage les vidanges plis pourriture
mais en même temps il donne un jeu quand
même le montage est finalisé la semaine
avant voilà c'est le montage peut faire
ce qu'ils veulent quand même temps ce
fut dessus tu veux tu caches et se
cacher la nature de quelqu'un c'est
exactement 10 millions d'années je sais
je sais qu'ils parlent pas comme coupé
foot qu'est ce qui fait que sisyphe août
par guère de répit tant donné ça
tournait tout le temps autour de ça il
faudrait qu'ils avaient de quoi qui se
passait dans trois maisons c'est tout
comme fo keven c'est un qui parle un
jour des vidanges les gaules est ce qu
un bout en bout de ligne c'est public
qui décide donc le public doit savoir
quelque chose qui m'est apparu qu'est ce
que tu penses que vous gagnez s'assoyait
ma petite russie 2 bompard c'est comme
les rues d'haguenau shine de dengue deux
semaines les deux dernières semaines le
montage change tout petit peu puis
saddam hauts étaient les deux dernières
semaines
ça dépend vraiment pas ce que c'est
normal chez les gens sont vraiment
influencé par la dernière chose qu'ils
ont vu le petit comme le justement
mettons mathieu dans l'épisode de
dimanche passé quitté fin était gentil
en amour faculty vos votes
automatiquement l'opinion publique
changé à son égard mais si mettons dans
les derniers épisodes d'une heure qui
vraiment plus bien montrer quoi que ce
soit ça donne vraiment des grosses
chances paraissent plus près d'un mois
de sacrifice face à un lièvre et la
tortue le piquer
ce serait beau c'est beau est ce que est
ce que tu changerais quelque chose ben
oui mais je me suis prononcé là dessus
maintenant si on sache à tout qu'est-ce
que chez moi dans mon parcours
j'aurais peut-être me j'aurais peut-être
donner un peu plus d'intérêt puis laissé
la porte ouverte aux disques plus a dit
m parce que c'est une fille j'ai vu les
émissions sur le fait qu'il se pare aux
tentatives il ya tout intérêt à mettre
avec qui et avec son intérêt envers moi
puis même en revenant c'est la veine
d'un contre nous autres même si j'avais
su la protéger ou à l'erreur c'est à la
règle plutôt d'un dans pioneer ont
démarré la deuxième maison pillon
bientôt com - finalement sinon je peux
pas je peux pas me battre pour mes
émotions bien ça tout est dans mon top
ça au total à vue mais c'est parce que
de ma part à moins que moi si une
opinion j'avais dès que j'ai amené à o2
j'avais dû juste comme farenc linth les
gens qui la connaissent la connaissance
une cliente à moins d'un obélisque
chaleur new york est ok si j'ai tout a
su qu'elle avait un nez derrière pour
moi mais déjà je trouvais que des fois
c'était un petit peu trouée un petit peu
trop facile mais tu es comme une
barrière puis je préfère chercher kidal
chasse mais tu saches à quelqu'un la
réception du public envers moi et elle
qui est si on était quasiment le
probablement vous auriez gagné si vous
étiez l'essence ont jusqu'à fin
exactement parce que tu dois
probablement tu gagnais aude et si tu te
rendes en finale belgique tout ça s'est
passé
et puis aussi avec avec l'opinion qui a
beaucoup de monde qui sont qui ont une
influence qui ont tout le monde l'aurait
définitivement parlé pour toi les droite
avait de bonnes chances de gagner au d
oui je me contentais de dickens de toute
chose c'est encore mieux
rendu là je préfère gagner car les
québécois qui gagne un condo le sait ce
qu'ils pensent que c'est ce concours
lieu du 15 octobre
je ne sais pas si tu dois passer à 100
estime je suis pas souhaité en même
temps il ya des jeux rien fait je suis
pas content que mon devoir pour moi puis
angeles
ce petit jeu j'aimais ça fait trois mois
que je véhicule fait qu'il repoussait
jeu ce malaise en aparté mais ouais mais
provenaient rajaona moi ça a été ma
fille je pense fêter ma fille bref
tradition le à damier par ses émotions p
t elle aurait pu aussi vraiment genre si
elle pu taper dessus
normal aurait pu décider déjà il ya les
emmène avec lui puisqu'on n'est pas
impossible mais je serai vraiment se
passe pas bien fait sur soi même par lui
et par sa tête haute pour ça cliquez ici
qu'est ce qui t'a attiré par camille
mettons qui a mis le pays ce qui en
faisait tellement pensé à un rail
scowcroft que j'avais eu chacun sur mac
c'est physiquement
c'est une fille qui m'attire beaucoup
cas mais j'aime beaucoup les grands
brûlés je trouve inquiétant cocasses et
qu'elles fêtaient farfelues et des rôles
très forts fallu un petit 600 nm rejoint
puis c'est agen et pau pour comme je
sais c'est à la cheville qui l'avait à
dégager de belle joie de vivre mais ça
c'est qu'est ce que moi je voyais ma
valeur des maisons ce jeudi dans le
confessionnal qu'est-ce qu'ils ont des
maisons jusqu'à lui les flux ce qui a
été influencée par les filles les
opinions défi que qualifie avait son moi
pourquoi
c'est dire que finalement georges je
dois jouer plus avec passer du temps
avec lui tu comprends ce que j'ai vu que
j'ai pas le temps que j'ai passé un test
et one seat antique au bopi c'est qu'on
étale à johannesbourg d'après plus à se
connaître dans des moments afghane puis
c'est vraiment un roman de johannesbourg
comme j'étais revenu j'ai regardé
jobbagy's j'appelle ma pauvre être dit
ceci je regarde pas les émotions juin va
s'affaisser juste que comme j'ai trouvé
ça plate dans les émissions de surtout
quand on était à côté moi qui reste
comme tu as tu sais pas j'ai trouvé ça
dommage mais si je me cacherais pas que
moi j'ai des gros je me voyais avec
l'impression que c'est premièrement
premièrement en voyage en général
souvent les relations puis c'est un
style vraiment plus rapide type il à
présent une émission comme ce qui était
le but ça se fait quasiment tout et tout
mais fois tu soutiens supposés être aux
aquariums
tout est accentué m l'impression que
comme vous avez tellement [ __ ] avec
les personnes qu'ils mettent envoyer une
partie 20 minutes le tu parles un peuple
qui s'assemblent cliquer j'ai
l'impression que projection qui se fait
de genre qui ces personnes là c'est la
femme de ma vie mais c'est d'enfants sur
le genre d'idéal que tout progrès dans
la personne puisqu'elle connaît pas
vraiment parce que oui je pense que
quand on fait pas mal sûr que toutes les
15 à vue n'ont vécu ça où vivre sans ce
moment jusqu'à temps qu'ils sortent de
là parce que quatre soit vraiment les
deux côtés de la médaille les opinions
de tous les candidats versus c'est ta
propre opinion d'eux
ne plains pas mais c'est le cas comme tu
commences à a changé d'opinion un petit
jeu on parlait de matt claudie tantôt je
pense que vers un beau panier je ne suis
pas un teg attentes et puis on la voit
j'aurai une belle joie de veepee talo
jean leloup cescom label labé pita
gaston aujourd'hui c'est bon là la vraie
vie va être le test ultime
mais j'en parlais justement un pop tort
que encore une fois au super que j'ai
fait avec son compteur soit maintenant
ça vient je n'ai pas vu les enfants on
parlait de ma relation avec ma blonde
qu'un conte est sorti daudet on était le
personnage péage qui sortait que le
personnage de 6 parce que tu te vois
tellement pas souvent que tu mets quand
même une façade en tête avec la personne
qui accentue certains traits tu démontes
pas d'autres traits de personnalité qu
tonnes puis en sortant aux autres il
fallut se déconstruire au complet puis
recommencer à ceux d'été hockey fait
genre de laisser tomber complément la
façade de fer qui regardons si ph et
jesse pour les personnages sont
fonctionnaires ensemble puis de se
rendre compte que qui si ça se fera
ensemble c'est la raison pour laquelle
il n'y a pas de coop qui tienne tu
comprends absolument pas ce que quand
déconstruite turcan 7 dt les chances qui
se trouve à quelqu'un qui quitte
intéressant où tout un terreau est ici
sont faibles quand même vraiment mais
mais c'est ça c'est que tu es quelqu'un
d'autre
puis quand tu tombes quand tu regardes
les émissions tu vois encore une autre
phase i est que la personne de démons
peu apprécié quand tu rencontres la
personne pour vraiment vite et
maintenant dans les maisons des exclus
le voyage final où après le voyage
fréquentes attend l'été le tout dans une
maison py tête avec la personne 24
heures sur 24
tu réalises qui a qu'il se sait les deux
vraies personnes ça marchera pas où ça
va marcher ou ou 7,7
gala sera pas un ami ou savoir
maintenant si c'est tout et c'est
vraiment c'est une fois simplifié à sa
plus basse où ça plus neutres personnes
c'est là que tu vois vraiment les gens
puis au dc pos ces noms des personnages
mars avec la il monte jamais les bottes
ou est-ce que c'est pas les personnages
parlent tout beau tout est ce que à
moins qu'il montera au des extras ou à
ce que les gars qui jouent ce cas où je
sais pas quoi les tirs mais sinon c'est
vraiment et c'est juste des personnages
qui parlent tout le temps en temps
quelques piques à ses captations du mois
si toi tu as vécu sûr mais quand ces
caps add captation tu tombes dans ton
personnage
oui c'est comme si c'est exact il
exactement
exactement c'est les captations ce que
le monde faut qu'ils comprennent la
maison sera obligé de comprendre si
s'ils veulent pas mais ce qui est
important de voir c'est que les
captations ces deux genres dans ta
journée au même pas même pas les impôts
c'est fx et comme c'est facile mais
d'être un personnage pendant deux ans
par semaine ce petit principal a bien
sûr être comme tout le temps je veux pas
être le gars de danane car c'est la
captation sebroko c'est rocco exactement
tout juste profiter du moment et avec
tout le monde ensemble
j'ai retrouvé qu'est ce que je voulais
dire trouve qu'on parlait de
l'intimidation puis il y fait que c'est
peut-être
ira-t-on at-on couach avec klose y théo
des sites ou des leaders mettons tout le
monde je pense que l'ars cuillère mais
cette année cette année la vibe était
quand même vraiment différent des autres
années ça a joué vraiment plus du qe2
qui ont conduit hors avant moi j'ai
trouvé je trouvais que - c'était
vraiment plus compétitifs mais moi ce
que je parlais moins d'empathie les uns
envers les autres en général avant le
début de l'émission surtout parce que je
pense qu'il ya deux affaires c'est
mettons je vais reprendre des ben ali
parce que c'est ce que je fais
c'est une zotac en est arrivé là c'était
juste des gars qui étaient qui étaient
soit capitaine dans leur équipe du rck
et qui étaient soit leader commande un
beau leader de leur groupe de musique
depuis qu'ils sont tout petits du monde
qui sont des leaders point pi 4 4 et un
leader toi tu me semble en être un ce
que tu as dit de dire de frenchy claudie
ok mais on est à odessa m'affecte pas
parce que tu eu cette confiance en toi
qui es l'heure exacte toujours et elop
qui est la raison pour laquelle les gens
en général
suivent trois personnes comme thirty
mois pour pau pour mon exemple cette
crise qui était de qui était dans mon
année cruciale qui lui est parti après
trois semaines et que ça a été trois
semaines a comme juste me bats chez moi
parce que son coup de coeur avait un
intérêt pour moi ça c'est comme
quelqu'un qui selon moi est en façade
d'un leader mais qu'il ya un manque de
confiance complet fait que j'ai
l'impression que si on j'appose rèset
cette espèce de terry le sueur dans ton
corps entier sait que mcit tu peux avoir
la façade d'un leader mais ce que tu es
vraiment c'est ce qui m'a vraiment eu
vraiment la confiance en toi désolé si
cette fille là m'intéressent c'est juste
normal qu'à l'intéressent d'autres comme
c'est juste normal parce que c'est une
fille belle qui est cher qui est
intelligente et c'est vrai que la raf en
date aussi le fait que j'ai l'impression
que c'est souvent lié à un manque de
confiance
c'est un gros match parce que mathieu
j'allais rencontrer cet été moi tout ce
qu'ils étaient au courant d'enfance et
c'est un ami un écologue ça donnait
qu'un jour
bref je me réveille puis mathieu dans ce
monde u20 disons bien brûlé ouais c'est
ça qu'est bon jason george ans + moi je
m'en allais pas si j'avais une grosse
journée prévue jambes ou la plage après
son sens au super après saint françois
enrichi mon agent et mon collègue
travail est fait penser à journée à
mourir je suis adroit et moi changement
à tour bien j'ai des montures les tangos
ont passé une belle journée
st je me suis occupé de lui bien chez
soi comme un con et des restos je paye
la traite si je paye la bière on
s'envoie la plage nana na na na li lé
lendemain matin j'étais parti travailler
puis mètres suite à mon corps et puis
alexis moi je t'ai vraiment confiant de
rentrer aux deux puis le jeune passer
une journée avec toi tu ne sais pas qui
mais non mais semaine je veux savoir
comment ça s'est passé
nous on était ils ont dit rejoins-nous à
tout le monde à l'hôtel le dauphin est à
longueuil puis on n'avait aucune idée ce
qui se passe et on arrive là et panneaux
solaires puis on est tout les goûts dans
une salle on était beaucoup avant le
tapis rouge dans les autres les combien
vous autres je pense qu'on était à une
vingtaine ont ainsi bloqué ouais on est
toutes les grâces en santé mais les
gaules mais on est assis dans salle
pendant une heure sans que personne qui
veut nous parler fait que là tu vois
tout le monde comme ok lui et calice
malade lui qui est l'autre qui comme
physiquement moins dans physiquement
universellement moins cher que toutes
les autres îlots pis il s'en rend compte
lui et lopy c'est de wever s'est placé
comme une espèce de jeu de pouvoir dire
un gros games dead analyse un gros game
2 qui sait comment moi je les ai vécues
mais j'ai l'impression qu'un homme qui
était convoqué moi j'essaie de pousser
le plus loin la voix le tu vois c'est
qui ceux qui ont une énergie de comme
louis philippe lucet comme inquiéter lui
aucun besoin d'eux
faites-lui lui va pas c'est que ces
plans en guest elle même parce qu'il ya
un espèce de jeu de pouvoir que ses
rentrées dos et comment s'est passé ton
était 8
on est tout tracé un après l'autre une
phase de rentrée caqueta moi je t'invite
dernier parce qu'on garde le meilleur
pour la fin
je rentre d'ailleurs qui nous attend
avec rem trois jours à passer dans
l'oeuf avec les experts les équipes les
exclus mais les candidats font écho les
terres on était toutes jouables et ils
ont dit garder dormi tout avec un avec
un autre gueule j'en fais que ces
matches si vous mangez moi je joue avec
dragos braga ça me faisait penser à
montcoal égalité beau bonhomme est
craquant mais assez tranquille le métier
qu'ils aiment pas être ses épaules et
accessoirement c'est ok je suis rentré
j'ai vu matthieu lahaye sa lutte jeu les
justes et tablettes ce qu'ils
connaissaient jour où je sentais pas
d'embarquer dans une game de genre
similaire à pezi pioli les relations
j'ai avec les candidats ou les candidats
je les dis tu fais à lui mathieu maps
est elle aussi on avait déjà tourné des
caps se lançant sur you to fakie je
connaissais déjà très mature et à tous
pas été super le tir à mi saison j'ai
trouvé que grâce à se calmer un petit
peu plus
plus j'y ai même dit à donner et
partager des très beaux à voir quand il
me tapait sénat je suis j'aime ça prend
de la place mais je commençais
l'occident dans ma manière d'agir puis
de redescendre la tension dans ce sens
que quand il joue drôle wever je
m'exprime bien pu tuer mais si jamais
comme jamais comme un mégaphone dans mes
poches puis écoutez moi tout le monde et
c'est moi c'est ce que ma table qui me
tenait un peu de matière en fait mathieu
lui contrairement à celui de la mala qui
m'avait il dit tout était pas mal plus
calmes qui est cash qui a vu cet été tu
sais ce que je rende en rendant une
aventure qui va changer ma vie de a à z
jassem à quoi m'attendre j'étais un peu
devant l'aude et je sais pas si keith
eagle fakty jetez pas nécessairement
monde analyse mais tiges tel homme j'ai
regardé les gars à qui c'est qui lui
pense que ce serait alors un peu
niaiseux
ok mais drôle si on parle de jeu parce
que lui il pensait que je n'étais pas
moi même à rentrer ami d'enfance et
jusqu'à quand mon père
maintenant un poisson dans un aquarium
c'est exactement ce titre vu comme une
journée avec eux bah ouais on est toutes
parts et puis on creepin on est là au
fait c'est ce que je te l'aï dit à mes
amis m'avaient du monde avec qui je veux
partager les trois prochains mois dans
la même chambre
si je les connais pas juste un petit peu
moins alive un peu ce que c'est qu'on
prenne un bon moment que là je ne sais
pas c'est que mathieu vous le savez les
deux puits draco
oui c'est quand même assez drôle si kaka
sauvé c'est moi c'est la journée de
montfaucon photo ch ou huit enfants dans
la nature vient de rebondir sa journée
mais photoshop il reste encore des
vaccins en fa cup et pépé papa tacle on
est les petits et les petits plats
strict avec les gens en place tout de
même passé et que tu vois ce que
j'arrive à maison plus moche et shinji
polaire clim qui faisait jointe à darois
de ces journées le fait que le marché
est aujourd'hui un mot colloque le tac
tac tac l'est de l'île dupas cm et une
pose pas de questions sur mes affaires
je sors de la maison et mathieu lafon
ils ont fait tout aussi bien son tee
shirt et plaster la lexie mon cousin
ghazi hamad tout pour que je pose une
question on convient que l'eau est
arrivée hier disque avec quad vraiment
il y avait de quoi des super important
faire maintenant mais il ne pas hésiter
quoi tout tu me dit quoi vraiment
important d'y descendre à menneville
petite surprise à ckoi pelé 12h et des
blindés place au célèbre aussi critères
essentiels en matière et di bello
je pense qu'ils t'ont cool qui fait audi
comme aux jeux c'est comme ça que ça
s'est su l'écart assez drôle en mai
matin que je me suis donné ce monde il y
avait des amis qui venaient puis il
arrêtait pas de meilleur philip crowley
je me suis fait piquer cette semaine le
joueur qui m'a regardé puis mon côté
j'avais aucune dire que lui ça va être
chaud
arrête aqip le sillage des petites
claques la photo schuman à l huile
akissi quoique à plus de 2
je vais peut-être la musique sur sa tv
sur youtube ce genre toutes mes
dernières recherches télécoms ou des
grès ou de science fiction la nana
meilleurs moments au détour d'un réalise
dans la recherche de voir le lier tous
deux lui seul ne dis pas que ça va aller
je n'ai pas mon mot 10 02 puis mousse
abaca par lazard est mort dix ans
c'était quand même temps vous parti
m'ont dit c'est le vrai 28 juillet dans
ces dates le 22 18
je sais que ce n'est que vers la fin
juillet ce qu on appelait ça ça a amené
les restes en amour mathieu lui tabacoop
away we go qui est choqué dernière
minute puis rentrer par défaut en plus
puis commente quand même et on ce
moelleux
ces deux mois la tvq pasky tu veux pas
faux sans rien savoir faut que tu m
un peu ta vie sur pause en ayant aucune
confirmation de rien se passer quoi le
tapis rouge ne sais pas si tu vas aller
directement télé tu dis vous allez en
afrique directement ou non
oui ok vous avez vu partout en afrique
peu importe ce qui se passe ils nous ont
dit de faire nos speech est deux jours à
l'avant 5 et vous n'aviez pas que
c'était des spectateurs dans l'exacte
amand bat ces deux mots le jésuite on
s'attaque été jeté aux lions je ne
saurai jamais dire à tout le monde mais
quand moi je ne suis pas de bonnes
relations avec mes boss ce que je trouve
la compagnie pour laquelle je travaille
dit c'est si j'avais des affaires à
gérer c'est à moi ce que je fais
vraiment parler puis de confier ce si je
joue quand même un rôle assez important
pour la compagnie mais pour laquelle je
l'espère longtemps que je serai présent
je m'entends vraiment bien avec toutes
les eaux place et puis j'en ai donné
beaucoup fait qu'il me donne énormément
parce que je suis
super reconnaissance digitale mais si ça
se fasse aux dépens du sud s'est proposé
même genre je te paie le loyer je vote
pas été si mauvaise affaire à gérer dame
au tibet non non non non non non puis
soir avoir ton nom ton post m survient
pas max et moi d'un certain sens j'étais
même pas me soucier de rien fallait
juste que je parte plus d'un titre
puisque ma valise soit bien fait ça
c'est vraiment vraiment fait que non
j'étais super chance vous pourrez alger
merci mike on pense là tu sors toujours
commencer à travailler non pas pour
l'instant je pense que d'une certaine
manière tu si j'allais réception que
j'ai du public en ce moment j'ai pas vu
je ne serais pas capable de faire ma job
aussi bien que je la faisais avant d'une
certaine manière parce que ses jeux
seraient bondé le monde viendra parler
prend des photos si je disais faut que
je reste professionnel j'ai tout fait
j'ai tout a été une personne
professionnelle car je travaille dans
n'est pas de quoi que j'entreprends
toute fin de match et j'ai comme le
désir de laisser retomber la poussière
un peu mais en même temps j'ai pas le
temps de jeu quand même à salma de ces
temps ci me sens pas bien pis c'est
d'une certaine manière j'ai pas
nécessairement envie de recommencer à
travailler fortement dans notre jeu
commence pas longtemps que je fais ceci
je voudrais tu es trouverez - voir les
portes les opportunités vont s'ouvrir à
moins dans l'âme et la tv
l'animation des trucs qui me passait
exactement c'est quoi le souverain
je vais acheter plus le gérant se
pressent depuis plus barman ce sens la
ramade sujet quand même une certaine
figure de leader c'est moi qui fais les
formations à chaque fois qu on nous dira
sera en fait c'est que je suis caché
saint lô même ceux ci sont en jeu le
faire de quoi où les violences ont mis
quoi le soir la lettre fait c'est ma
quatrième année au canada
ça me fait du bien
québec sortent elles plus là mais il ya
pleinement 26 mettons sandri clermont
large que j'ai jamais vu et tout la même
monde que monde connaît tout le même
monde que moi je n'ai jamais vu
29 sûreté tube ou doit on connaît mais
je compte jamais j'en donne même pas
vendredi
c'est vous parlez vous cette fois
j'étais à la bourre 9
ok tu te regrette mon ex en fait rien de
mort et la connaîtra pas remettre dans
le temps du 4 x des housses au dessus ça
se voit non saisonniers peut-être
qu'avec mon chariot bureau poste au
revoir à leur poste soit bâti le bureau
postal c'est là maïs et ça c'est le même
cas que moi j'ai commencé d'abord de
mettre un ace puis gérer ce que la même
compagnie depuis ce temps leur puis il
tombe super mario toutes ces pages voir
l'addition en fait on en voit trop
rivière
ça faisait déjà deux ans cherche pour le
bureau de poste mais comme elle est
formulée boorman à bob c'est un public
que j'ai commencé à avoir un indice peu
plus de responsabilités en tant que
barman un fait que chez les femmes la
formation j'étais libre là-bas puis
bouchard ville comment au début de l'été
puis trop violent et essais sur des
forges le centre-ville est l énergie
faillite si elle garde au plus je vais
déménager à trop revient loyer beaucoup
parlé c'était payant mais je n'ai pas
que ça à dire en ville font attendre
l'hiver
j'ai trop de talent on le met durant
l'hiver on avait déposé projet pour
ouvrir un deuxième point aux enfants à
montréal puis jésus belle moi je suis ta
que je m'en méfie de québec j'ai
graduellement fait moins jusqu ici
jusqu'à moi j'ai pris un petit break les
piemme puis qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce
tu veux faire maintenant c'est quand
même temps tu disais des aspirations
animation télé
ce serait quoi mettons bâti c'est drôle
de l'objectif en matant
c'est un peu dernière minute j'ai fait
avec sarah jeanne labrosse ok mais cette
fois je garde cette créance avoir
développé les bientôt mais on était
juste et des chemises opodo où ça va
être présenté qui voit exactement mais
je suis pas content le touche une belle
porte d'entrée qui ont en effet
l'activité animation radio avec dieu et
je me sentais tellement à l'aise pour
dire que c'est là que je me suis dis
hein je préfère de quoi avec sortie j'ai
une idée concrète je te dirais que non
mais c'est parce que justement je peux
recommencer à travailler dessus et je
crois qu est-ce que qu'est-ce qui va
voir qu'est ce qu'on veut sur ce qui va
se présenter à moi puis prendre le temps
de peut-être m'a serré avec du monde
avec des bonnes idées puis dessiner un
projet puis il ya les comme ceux dont le
redis ce que ça fait pareil parce que tu
vois justement qui un talent naturel
pour faire ce genre de chose le type
l'an passé c'était vers une authentique
que justement c'est de mettre devant un
kodak puis comme ici nationale s'est
passé livres mais cette année puis toi
toi s p est sujette à malte et la vie
droite mettant en fait qu'est-ce que
pousser d'aller faro des puits est ce
que mettons le film instagram c'est
quelque chose que toujours recherché
aubin toujours rechercher non j'y serai
postez pas que c'était pas comme une
aspiration que l'aide pourrait avoir un
certain flou ayant fait le disque me
pousse à frauder moi je pense que j'ai
quand même une personnalité assez
flamboyantes les tiges et excentrés puis
jeudi un dribble jeu mais quand je me
cache pas pour le faire puis la charité
jjj un énorme réseau amical partout à
travers québec montréal trois rivières
québec puis un peu partout parce que
justement pour qu est ce que moi je
dégage en tant qu'être humain je
comprends ma personne et puis mes amis
qui me faisait six filles très bon du
tout faire péter
l'an passé je les vois faire les
auditions j'ai rencontré une fille qui
fidèlement georges avait jugé trip et
ben raide sur fx a jamais traversé
l'idée de commettre deux côtés puis
mitsuru pour passer les auditions mais
fait que cette année je m'étais dit
gages mais quand je suis prêt je suis
prêt à affronter sa petite voix qu'est
ce qu'est ce que ça va donner puis juste
par contre de l'avoir fait une belle
expérience
c'est quoi teralight mairie light
c'est ben may de voyage que les
activités que j'ai fait pour ouvrir la
relation que j'ai eue avec chris
sacristie bon jack crise pour il
t'attend du 7e match comptant pour lui
prouver c'est vraiment cool tant mieux
ça va moins non johanesbourg c'est
vraiment fou - c'est vraiment cool
ces gens réunis mercredi passé c'est
justement la soirée comme of calmes
qu'on a eu ce soir et le on était avec
nous nous sommes vus puis on était dans
fourmoy crise qui a mais pippa lee noble
on est allé souhaitiez pas séparés non
on était celle des quatre ans sont avec
nous deux nous sommes calmes ce système
c'était fou on était super petit jeu les
joueurs de super tapage puisqu'on a
comme un brin d'acier apps iphone jovial
puis on a bu puis on dit souvent on a
dansé et puis le tout dans un décor ils
seront envoyés comme la métropole comme
ça bouge toi puis on voit la mettre un
peu de beurre terme à ce genre de soirée
que je pense ici à montréal juste sur le
steak and haas je suis pas aux dés en ce
moment je suis bien il n'y a pas de cas
mais pas demain qu'on peut dire ce qu'on
veut c'est vrai a mal fait son immense a
été un de mes meilleurs sauts rue
c'est sûr que ma mère soit restée mais
dans la soirée à joburg séverac ou parce
que ça ne pourrait en fait de cliquer
pour voir la réaction la plus longue
étape de moyens on est à prendre des
photos pts 10 c'était plaisant je
regarde la juste des bons signes pour
rire c'est drôlement plus plu est plus
même le plus éloigné de même mon passage
à rodez plus tout le négatif s'en va
plus les souvenirs positifs restent mois
comme maugis quelques moments que je
sais que je dois être mon alignement
joie fort ok je me rappelle de ce mois
ça valait tout à ça pour ça ouais ouais
les affaires que tu pourras jamais de
payer alors si c'est exactement nous
avons l'artiste à profit tout ce pis
pour ceux qui l'achèteront sortait à
faire des activités insultes
je reste poli avec le monde était
remerciements si c'est pas
nécessairement aux autres les mrc à tout
le monde
merci foule je l'appris si je prenais
temps de le dire et le jeu postes
importants jusqu'à quand
capt être que positive qui passent leur
parle attaque le gêne pas pour le dire
au monde sait et je vais étudier quoi un
partage des moments là avec qui on est
merci beaucoup c'est vraiment fort
j'apprécie ton manteau et ben beau ou le
tir je ne saisis pas le temps d'un juste
partage est libellé belle passe est
possible qu'ils pensent à travers la
trêve tout le monde apprécie autant que
tout apprécié ce monolithe
et oui mais c'est un challenge qu'on
s'en rende compte
voir des moments positifs moi j'achète
pas moins que si steph il incarne souris
estime disposer de pose des questions
mais c'est parce que tu es en train d'en
vivre maman partage là et on réalise
réalisent leur hippie propagent les oies
vraiment c'est une belle vision de la
pâte en stars venues intervenu dimanche
fait que lundi
j'avais défini j'avais des finalement
lundi facturés dans ma famille j'ai vu
tout le monde qui est j'ai été chassé
n'a selon les magrets qui circonstance
parce que toute ma famille était là mais
deux familles s'entend super bien fait
mais deux familles est elle de retour
dans la vraie vie pour moi c'est le
premier contact que j'ai eu avec mon
poste pour m'annoncer que mon grand père
était décédé chaînon qui sait qu est ce
que c est ce qui était malade avant
qu'il parte faisait de parkinson mais on
craignait pas pour sa vie en soit moitié
moins que ce qui la fonde et finira il
s'était dit certain retour mais il au
tour de taille mais c'est une autre
étape attendue non construits non
vraiment pas d'enfant moi j'ai reçu la
nouvelle le jeu il dit dans le fond tu
m'envoies l'était déjà séduit pour eux
samedi fait j'avais à montréal le
dimanche l'ief noé était lundi au
lac-saint-jean fait cacher à l'aéroport
ils m'ont envoyé une femme puis on a
roulé cinq heures de temps jusqu'à ses
fictions lac saint jean tous eu d'ennuis
j'ai pas dormi je me suis habillé je
t'envie on est arrivé là bois qu'ils
menaient 3 1 jeudi matin j'étais encore
ce gros décalage horaire les funérailles
est à 8 heures le mes parents ce jeudi
il avait trouvé que m'avait pas vu
qu'ils ont vu leur amende
on a jasé avec le souverain en amérique
bien s'envoler avec ça a été assez
raquel rometty tout ça pour dire que
j'ai pris peur de le dire à tout le
monde
merci merci j'ai une belle famille puis
le lendemain j'avais un parti de retour
qui avait que la prod ailleurs games
awards pis si j'ai fait un speech
contrat je suis contente avec 0 puis
d'avoir du monde
j'ai beau monde comme ceux qui
m'entourent parce que les six pas tout
le monde sur cette chance on sait que
vos différents soucis après quand tu
reviens d'une expérience aussi fucked up
déjà intelligent contact at green deal
opérateurs mais tu entends ton vrai si
je me souviens certains candidats
on le voyait justement condamné les
retours dans les familles se dit tu
voyais diana vie qui venait leur famille
c'est un gros party et puis à neuvic qui
rentrait piste -comme et d'autres aux
personnes petits tracas qui finalement
la personne est aussi entourée que c'est
comme trio dans un sens je sais pas ce
que tu voyais aussi des personnes qui
qui avait certains struggle
dépôt pour le support qui pourrait avoir
un petit qu'un certain qu'ils méritent
dans cette école ouais mais tant mieux
si toi c moi pilou pilou on est des amis
dans la vie pour ne pas cela fait deux
semaines à faire la tournée des bars
dont saint georges de beauce et samedi
puis dimanche
c'est une autre homme de québec sont
venus tous y avait des affaires fait en
bosnie sont venus déjeuner bio que vous
êtes dans l'erreur d'avoir descendu
c'est juste d'avoir juste avant le
déjeuner reste un bon segment de
servisair qui ça veut dire qui quitta
précipite on s ennuie mme way vraiment
c'est cool c'est s'offrir un coup c'est
encore amis il est au pilori les dix
d'entre eux parce que tu le caches par
les moteurs des commentaires négatifs
qui leur servait de médiamétrie ce gie
panier en fait souligne un gars qui m'a
écrit un livre bd comme louis pas bon
pour moi jusqu'à je ne connais pas
sharon a cassé ce genre tu ne connais
pas je connais pas louis ii pour la
création de vue narratif en dehors de
2,25 et bourrés de talents lèvent à la
bonne place pour chiara bonne place
pigalle est mentionné dans mon lave avec
un nom j'ai dit je sais pas quel monde
vous prenez un deux minutes plus de gens
vraiment apprécié ce gueux le la mer que
moi je le vois pas ce que c'est tout
qu'est ce que votre chien dans la vie ça
retourner dès lors du gros succès plutôt
puisqu il ya plus en conversation va
tendre que j'ai eue avec lui qui ont pas
été mon trou sa caméra facture d'un
certain sens ils ont su je sais tout je
sais pas si le montage faire en sorte
qu'ils aient commis perçu comme un
vilain méchant petit jeu c'est qui a été
évoqué l'influencé des maisons dans la
deuxième maison avec cap matures moi je
les adore des semaines avec des mots qui
te répète à chaque jour qu'est ce que le
signe vidange à manille c'est benoit
scheen nuit ça pour ça puis maire on a
passé trois semaines en exclu et coria
et puis on s'est presque pas leur celle
de pluton est revenu au québec
l'ensemble je pense que ce cela en dit
assez pour que j'appelle la meinau pilou
et on est des jump y disparaîtra et si
possible pour un truc tu sais c'est mon
ami mais si les gens maison lyon peut
toutes les informations pour pouvoir se
prononcer l'été n'empêche qu'ils ont vu
un show qui monte certaines choses se
sont montrés d'autres sont pas montrés
six mois pour lavaur vph l'habillage est
arrivé jeudi au teil telle affaire oui
c'est vrai ce côté ce que tu as vu le
meilleur tout c'est au tour qui qui qui
met son un contexte parce qu'on a pas vu
piquer kiki qui aide à comprendre les
choses latifah qui l'a classé 7e c'est
drôle aussi les gens qui se prononce pas
qu'ils pensent
c'est à voir vraiment le connaître la
vraie nature de chacune des personnes tu
es si oui béton d'écouté mission pis si
clairement mettons camionnette un petit
peu montré comme l'a pas fait mais avant
de temps avant d'arriver ici pitot dans
le micro qui est une cible est une
souche de la connais pas les dépôts j'ai
vu certaines bordel meetic est très un
contexte qui pour un contexte normal
était probalement encourager
l'innovation elle aussi à dire des
choses à draper des bombes comme ça
c'est parce que les autres c'est ça qui
sont mécontents à petit avant de juger
cette personne-là ou qui que ce soit et
on les connaît pas il faut se garder une
petite gêne paris je pense que je pense
qu'il faudrait commencer à parler de ces
choses là en disant mettons camille dans
occupation double afrique du sud était
comme sur ce quoi c'est pas dire
qu'amélie comme ça pas dire cacher comme
ceux d'hier ph temps au débat lee a été
comme ce jeu c'est vrai parce que c'est
ce qu'a démontré
ça reflète un peu comme qu'est ce que
disait danton la fois des personnages le
teaser personnage audi atv puis on s'est
tu perds tu peux tu peux vraiment comme
joueur personnages à rodez où tu peux
jouer la carte de comme c'est
authentique de rased aussi c'est
différent il faut juste que tu dises que
comme certaines actions certaines choses
que tu dit dans l'émission ça fait pour
refléter la personnalité à 100 %
exactement exactement puis la personne
qui a écrit
juste par curiosité la personne qui
écrit ce paragraphe loi complet le futur
guide son profil non mais non pas parce
que souvent mais moi je moi je me plaît
c'est de comprendre ou non mais dans
l'analyse
je me faisais attaqué sur les réseaux
sociaux pique un précieux j'ai eu accès
à tout seul au début je déconne leurs
cliques se profile ce genre qui garde 13
le petit gars de 13,1 est ce que ça vaut
la peine que je prenne soin à caracas
sam blessés est ce que vraiment comme
ils pensent tous qui disent qu'il
réfléchit à saubens fait juste dire ça
parce que je sais pas vraiment écrémé
salle accueille ses amis à côté on pense
à sa charge un crime c'est beau c'est
beau mais je vois pas perdre de
l'injection mais ça y est fallu je les
réalise ce parce qu'au début mais tout
le positif c'est cool le planant sur 100
qui est négatif c'est un challenge pour
moi c'est sur un tête à tête ce genre
ton est répond pas mal à tout le monde
au début oui maintenant non ok
maintenant maintenant sur le tourisme en
moins le message que la relève le 2 en
mai mais non un petit peu juste pour
nous répond c'est impossible
on sait juste qu'elle se moque mais
quand on nous fait partager c'est manger
je sais pas comme un crime chez pas
comment j'ai fait jusquà s'aigrir du cac
champagneur qui escaladent d'aubin
partie cassé des beautés mine des beaux
témoignages match comptant de répondre
non sens en mai puis soudain tout est
justement totem populaire le sou de là
aussi le représentant joe de cause
j'imagine qu'ils apprennent mon kit
écrivez nous il était victime
d'intimidation puis danois n'ont pas
poteau
non pas tant j'ai vraiment jusqu'à un
regard de t'être forte bla bla bla c'est
juste du gros lot mais je pense que
c'est je pense que personne qui comme
qui s'est vu vraiment l'idée non pas
tant des fois quand il devient une
figure publique le tri des gens qui
ressentent le besoin parce qu'ils
connaissent le titille ont l'impression
de te connaître parce que ton vue puis
titan suivi longtemps puis dit les gens
qui qui qui se confie comme ceux par
messages à des inconnus à qui je suis
j'en suis très fier nature à la menthe
il ya eu des mauvaises que j'aurais pu
péter ma que je plains puis auprès qu'hp
t mac os mais christ c'est comme ça que
je pète mac os sa maison c'est le genre
j po ge est possible de mettre un filtre
rien parce qu'il y avait des cas mais
restait vraiment le moi moi moi moi puis
tout de même ils ont tout le temps dit
yes c'est sûr ça si kiev à sa cinquième
quelques heures c est sur ces petites
révélé avec un plan de match était de
l'impro delonge plan de match bah oui
puis non sens que je ne cache pas que je
vais vraiment le puits vraiment je lui
dis dans mon top ou moi je voulais qu'on
quitte et toutes les filles les faits
mais batista comme c'est pas mal ça je
me sentirai que là il y avait deux
maisons mais tu sais ces questions je
mettais dit pour qu'il joue un peu
d'inde under tout en restant un petit
peu comme discret nana na na na avait
pas au pied mais si j'étais pas là pour
faire des choses et ce pour la personne
non plus un rêve c'est un damné je
t'aime quand je me suis rendu compte que
le faisait m des bâtonnets ou henrique
gigue en fête elle-même je sois mon show
le séjour juste femmes et enfants de mon
côté c'est joli digère en fait j'ai
réécouté com
une scène aujourd'hui par hasard sa
commande une même bassin est ce que je
reviens 5 à 7 du ski et calmes indiqué
temps imparti au musée puis en tout cas
fait jusque chez se disent les gueux
l'expédition plus de savoir à quelle
heure je peux dessus comme juste
magazine et monty géré disais mon petit
jardin puis sa personne pile dedans le
juge fox et laissons le tranquille
celui ci personne en bout de cinq ans
jane un parti bleu c'était utilisent
cette faute et camille de résident
depuis le début mais quand jane et
participe sujet l'idée à cargèse belle
ça me facilite les choses parce que je
peux juste me concentrer surtout a
depuis jeté sur lui même car je n'ai
participé qu'à remettait plus qu avec
louis mettons dans pas mal de projets
n'ont pas nécessairement ben oui puis
non sujets abordés proche si je vais pas
voir de la tâche qui tout en appréciant
monsieur g par année qu'est ce que je
ressentais rien mais attire 10 affichant
son alternateur on aille dans ce sens
quelqu'un c'est alain médicale à 20
coups de fouet pour lui puis s'était
fait un voulait plus rien savoir mathieu
gibaud j'ai arrêté je le porte comme un
charme certain match et comme je suis
j'étais plus ou le rejeter vraiment
comme je n'ai pas fait justement pilar
mettant à part ça personne ne s qui
maintenait dit maintenant avoir ta
connaissait pauvres mais nantes à
connaître aux allemands parce que la
personne qui est qu'elle ict a découvert
qu'elle était dans ces trois semaines le
sens quimper qui ne pas être intéressé
ou non non
m non c'est comme un mélange de regarder
les émissions puissent voir son côté moi
je voyais pas puis juste en dessous en
général une super de belle fille je
m'entends bien avec camille métier est
ce que je partage ma vie avec à main
avec un frigo camille non tranché on
cuisinait beaucoup ensemble on avait du
fun mais jusqu'à côté personnalités des
nouveaux intérêts sont comme vraiment
différent fait ça ferait que comme ça ça
n'aurait pas pu marcher en bout de ligne
en même à certains des mêmes s'ils vous
serez pas le je pense pas que je serai
plus aboutir à de quelconques raid en
sortant des stands sur le futur budget
n'est fait depuis 2006 ouais j'avais dit
qu'on va se battre autant mail mois puis
jhen on s'entend super bien
vraiment vraiment bien qu'ils étaient là
mon parti mon parti de râteau mais
poussé mais pas rentrer le sodium en a
marre elle a envoyé un message à johnny
space bouquin sorti et puis on s'entend
c'est pas bien ensemble
non je pense qu'on ne se passer du temps
mais en même temps c'est justement je
viens d'arriver
moi j'ai pas envie de jeu pas envie de
m'investir dans quoi tu solide en ce
moment je te dis pas que je ne dis pas
que j'écarte l'idée ou à l'inversé jusqu
en ce moment il était mal choses qui se
passent 60 ans pas de commencer à voir
une autre bulle lui ce qu'il faut que je
mette de l'intérêt de la mairie à
l'énergie là dedans il ya trop de choses
qui se passe en ce moment tu jusqu'à fin
mai à fin juin l'autre jour j'étais je
me fais pas de plan je sais pas
qu'est-ce que je reçois je sais je sais
que dans mon temps à lire je sais pas
qu'est ce que je dois faire pisser bain
car i can say they dessus sur tours de
c'est un peu pardon tu es tour du simple
ou de sa non pas vraiment moi le
problème je prends ce parvient puis
j'aime savoir des semaines il ya des
semaines comme cette semaine comme un
matin j'ai eu mon tournage
un tournage et je pense me parle
beaucoup à gaza exonère 50 ans et plus
moi je monte à québec mercat disent pas
autre chose je lui ai dit at a time
j'adore ce gars qui sait je trouve ça
vraiment copie c'est une fois la prime
va shooter décompterait à faire de même
ça va super bien je suis en comptant
puis c'est je pense que c'est pas tout
le monde nous c'est qui qui qui veut se
quittent à l'aise avec site je sais que
certaines personnes qui sont aixoise au
doublé comme rien savoir des
référenceurs dans son domaine mais moi
je commence et je suis de plus en plus à
l'aise puis je pense que ça va juste pas
comme ce facteur xa l'accès j'adore sur
pizarro super bien bon tant mieux tu
t'étais sur instagram pas mal ouais
ouais ouais je suis humble plafond que
je suis est pas mal c'est moi j'avais
potente j'avais pas
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est qu'aux réactions d'estoril aimé
qu'il soit là qui une fois au jardin
troisième rang qui les attend mais
nantes on compte instagram me doit être
pas mal plus effectif à ce genre de
technique nul comme à caterpillar est
pour la tour phare loupé ce qu'il
fallait au bac
comment m c'est bon c'est une fois
qu'une fois qu'elle premier une faute
après midi m t'envoyer c'est quoi la
suite l'est
[Musique]
mais pour briller pour s agit comme j'ai
pas le temps à cordes et à vent ou
d'utiliser le fait que rembrandt et je
travaille ce soir c'est ce que je suis
ici j'essaie de faire différer pour
creuser mais six jours déplore et
l'argent de barry pour reprendre la
route de le beurre et l'argent du beurre
et moi la joie l'utile à l'agréable
voilà pourquoi tu avais tu
moi je sais que les gars qui sont sortis
de mon année c'est le batteur il y avait
des news
dd nous du temps dans leur 10ème ne se
remplit pas non pas moi tout prix nous
disons non j'ai pas nous dit non non non
deux ans avait cherché quelqu'un qui a
renvoyé seul il ya de la place dans ma
boîte et 64 gic le seul face à ses
dégâts les vieux non mais bon c'était un
enfant plus tard à nos ennemis que je
mènerai paix pour protéger son anonymat
scrapbook de toutes ses conquêtes
on y est allés sur facebook puis il y
avait non seulement fait un scrapbook
avec la photo des filles mais à un prix
la faute aux défis au moment où est-ce
qu'ils avaient couché avec fait
maintenant y retourner daltin mais non
dans leur façon leurs cinq marques
marques à son nom n'était pas une cour
avec la photo jusqu'à ramener c'est
quand qu'il est en passe plutôt rendu
comme autour de 30 peut te dis c'est un
peu oui d'avoir un scrapbook avec une
free dès 16h si moi j'avais 16 ans au
début comme un milieu d'intrigants
j'ai entendu un cri d'un podcast des
gueux qui répond à des questions plus
gai y avait et a posé une question que
les deux roues du poker sont incapables
de répondre je vais vous poser cette
question là qui cachait des nazis
le guide il ya 25 ans il serait quand
même fille depuis à peu près 8 ans puis
dit le t1 le jour est parti plus je
voulais m'assurer b en checkant la
blonde c'est des photos de bikini sa
branche qui somme toute correct qui fit
des fidèles au bout mais lundi il dit le
problème c'est que je tombais à ces
photos plus logique j'ai fait ce que
j'avais à faire sa photo pour réaliser
qu est une photo d'elle à 17 plein dit
fait que je me suis comme crosse et un
tchèque un tchèque a une fille de 17 ans
c'est ma blonde le jeu comprend le
messin fille de 17 ans c'est quoi votre
opinion sur cette question la réponse
des guides pas de casser comme je
comprends la question ce que tu aurais
dû faire s'ils ne jamais en parler c'est
d'être que je pense à ce mal tu jamais
écrit dans un bas de casse pour qu'on en
parle
tu vois c'est la raison pour laquelle
les couillons pas répondu mais pas le
bonheur est dans le fait qu'à son habit
qui ne peut pas qualifier ça de
pornographie juvénile
parce que c'est une photo d'une fille en
maillot de bain mais met un terme à
quelque chose là en tout cas écrivent
des commentaires
ob votre opinion on veut l'opinion de
tout le monde qu'est ce qu'on souhaite
même qu'est ce qu'on ne soit à toi
belle continuité du succès d'un entre
mille beau projet
m d'être et de rester au rue
saint-vincent tue l'amour l'amitié
il reste un tournage important dans
l'histoire daudet oui comment ça s'en
vient l'heure de vérité pour tous
comment tu vois sur votre voiture et là
mon vieux savage montauban 22 pris le
temps trop de relaxer puis de prendre la
distance stop mais c'est un peu l'idée
de midas ans qui comme moi j oui je
mange ma valeur pour recevoir des
excuses en premier plus que d'autre
chose
puis wigig d'arrivée avec le contourner
et d'armes et si c'est pas moi j'ai pas
une personne de même d'avis tout est
joli nez pointé tout le monde se doit
c'est arrivé mon site mon chien ma nana
na na na c'est ce que tu sais quand même
pas une petite haie je pense avec plus d
affaires des petites créances et à
toutes de nana na na na nana na na car
j'arrive avec mon canon puis à voile le
basque hôpitaux serait plus calme ici
elle est juste pour parce que je peux
dire exactement ce qui va se passer
sevré tracy le pilote je veux dire
une thématique qui revenue souvent
pendant l'émission peas et les
commentaires de de mathieu par rapport à
quelques mois fait qu'on va regarder un
montage le tout arrive là même un club
avec l'idée d'être laid back halle
plaide allez vous tourner ma télé procès
est un pur montage
toutes les fois où l'on peut apprécier
vos savoirs venez plonger votre garder
votre geste en pense
c'est ce qui va se passer le celle du
dessus qui est fait qu est-ce qu comment
tu veux réagir à ces commandes du pape
sera géré à sa part sur les autres le
monde qui vont occuper la case on peut
en juger par lui-même comment finalement
tu réagis à seul mais sur le coup quand
tu vas voir sur qui va être l'heure tu
vas avoir été servi comme il veut avoir
signé pendant deux saisons complet plus
tu vas l'avoir d'en face tu voir revoir
ces moments le puits va être à côté de
tous ces soucis c'est sûr je lisais déjà
usé mission un moment ma réaction quand
je voyais cgt jusqu'à
arlac jean vide soudain lâché le morceau
je pense que je vais pouvoir avoir cette
mentalité là dans ce sens qu'elle compta
barnabas urgent à quoi tu as pensé une
élite a mentionné justement le fait que
tout qu'est ce qui est dit et fait évier
et film peint que siemens qui portait
pas donné le film mon goal com tu peu
comme si on a juste vu ta vraie nature
puisqu'il est pas juste une zone calme
et le québec au complet le vul je pense
pas qu'ils réalisent là les pacs avoir
fait genre s'ouvre sur lui jean py sa
vie en ce moment parce qu'il mène il va
l'avoir flottille ont fermé les
commentaires instagram pu tout changer
tout le monde le beh si c'est ce que tu
sais je pourrais rejouer le pied envoyer
chier tout le monde le sais je comme
gsip goldman pressenti chanter suisse ni
qu'ils y en a comme enjeu la gelée
craque au monde c'est évident mais dans
des trous j'écris des africains passent
des bottes à ça ça va être jalouse quel
membre et comme barbare mais je pense
que je vois juste plus là dessus que tu
arrives et jean rey
c'est vraiment comme un jeune croisé les
bras
je recommande de vous parce que
maintenant tu sais que ça t'affecte puis
ça m'a fait plus partie la plus belle
réception qu'on aurait pu demander
pourquoi daudet en ce moment le brillant
je pense qu'ils aient comme justement si
je gagne le candidat klaus avons juste
de 1 prouver genre que comment j'ai été
du début de résident de mon parcours
mais même ça va les faire chier en
tabarouette ou s'il est probablement
ouais mais un jardin qui vont revenir
mais ils vont avoir écouté les émissions
ils vont avoir vécu le reste idée de
comme réaction aux émissions de leurs
bornes à ceux qui tout le monde avait
payé en deux minutes par une action
partie sans doute qu'à ma thuôt sylla en
cave envers tous et ça serait pas aussi
rendue en train de vivre une vraie mois
surtout qu'ils étaient ils étaient plus
de menace pour lui fait non c'est que
noël c'est sûr mais je pense que c'est
je cède à sanaa je pense que je pense
qu'il m'aime dans tous les jours aussi
le s'il a montré une intensité
incroyable parce qu'il ya une forme de
wiki comme ça dans la vie de tous les
jours ça mais la loupe sur quelque chose
c'est ce qu'on disait tente ou renouveau
de la confiance est vraiment sûr en fait
une émission que west l'état des sites à
des travers ou d insécurité ça mais la
loupe là dessus qu'ils étaient faites le
tri tiges de mon amie holly quelqu'un au
likoud qui quelqu'un qui est gage temps
de confiance qui est drôle qui est à
l'aise dans vie dans des contextes de
même ne sais pas comment tu vas ranger
et puis ça y ajouter parce que je le
connais mais
et c'est ce type y est c'est ainsi
qu'ils m'emmènent est un risque à
prendre pareilles dans les luttes que tu
sais je sais pas comment tu vas être
montré je sais pas comment tu vas être
perçu sa sépulture dead le t1 rôles
comme tout véhicule s'appliquera dès le
détester mendy pitié au bowling avec le
temps aussi les gens se calment
j'apporte à autre chose puisque le
public est tellement télé publique et
des fois plus intense qui se moque lit
candide express de plus à coeur au
creusement sur le patient et qui traîne
ce qu'elle n'a que ça en est
incompréhensible et comme si leur vie en
dépendait
un gain de madame qui je rappelle
toujours de ma langue est venu le voir
on sortait du classement pts j 1
québec la pyramide oui madame qu'il nous
voit et se met à trembler ce pas pleurer
gens paniquent en disant que c'est nous
qui aurait pu gagner et étant la couleur
comme cisco et chez dans l'ubs à celle
au ping pong club à pression
j'allais tourner une cachette avec mon
ami alex a besoin de gens récupèrent
récupérions récapitulatif des lui c'est
qu'on est d'écouter puis j'aime encore
là hubbard j'embarque dans le choc qui
j'avais pas vu au dix9 savait qu'on
parlait de
la maison 10 actuel avec amiens pile oui
j'ai déjà fait savoir si j'écoute un
petit sketch on en change vite fait
avant la minceur est peu probable que j
mission puis aussitôt que la chanson
thème apparemment je suis le côté people
on avait tous envie et ça m'a fait
sourire tout le long de la rue mais
qu'est ce que tu penses d'être sûr
toulon le tfc je prends le temps aussi
jose avec le monde salue comment ça vous
squattant n'ont pas sauvé journée
continue à faire cette tournée des bars
ont contractuellement par les faucons
soyez logique à peu près une heure et
demie deux heures pile où il est on a
tellement fort qu'on est tellement
choyée par la montée des eaux jusqu'à 2
3 eur puis à wels éric lapointe à 3h15
de booth ont commencé à s'écailler une
heure et demie les nanas et autres lady
gaga en plus on est gros fort bien et on
se fait dans le monde ils se déplacent
pour nous voir ils passent une heure
dans la line up pourquoi moi je resterai
pas une heure de plus d'arbres a juste
gardé mon sourire puis prendre des
champions va défendre et prendre des
photos le en bout de ligne ça fait son
affaire la soirée la journée puis
peut-être la semaine à certaines
personnes qui en ont vraiment besoin
d'un des finances norman ses autres
définitivement c'est vraiment très cool
man tu as l'air de bien faire ce que je
fais du mieux que je peux disait qu'on
souhaitait de continuer de seraing puis
d'être bien d'être heureux c'est que le
sacré de kevin même près tous seraient
même pas ce qu'est ce qui m'a frappé
manta sérénité face à dire si tu es
maintenant ses missions c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui est bien dans la vie que
confiant ce type
ces scouts ont fait écrire mais mes
parents m'ont tout le temps ils m'ont
tous temps quand mes disques et d'un
positivisme ne recense que quand faut
toujours garder positif c'est le bon
côté des choses je mentionnais temps
tourne au grand père était décédé puis
et aux moyens mort dans son sommeil avec
une belle montre cet accord il ya tout
un droit qui shine de l'autre côté du
nuage
si cette fossiles ce qu'il faut focus
aide en bout de ligne je me rappelle un
damné des maisons si on forme surtout là
dessus qui a rien donné il dit
plantage prévu à l'excès et puissante
comme dutroux j'étais quand même savoir
la famille venue bella je comprends pas
et au 2e tour je sais pas combien photo
auditionné je sais que c'est ton rêve de
passer à tv de passau 2 mégawatts et 17
en ce moment puisque les friches de la
con à la bouillie rempli mais non ne pas
dépasser une christine pour leur emploi
on y jette en afrique du sud
on a la chance d'avoir des crises
thibault voyage même si ce foutu focus
les petits et les petits une heure ou
deux qui se passa rien d'âge on n'a pas
le droit de lui il va passer ça deux
hommes étaient trois mois dans un des
plus des pays les plus diversifié de la
planète autant cultuelle que c'est de la
forme si c'est fou la finition
l'histoire est tellement riche labo on
petit focus là-dessus à place positif
tout le temps à toutes et à tous leurs
crises qui se marie toi maison positive
tout le temps et je pense aussi que ça
me vient en tête c'est de parler aussi
de ses émotions s'est séparé
c'était à prendre s'exprimer si jamais
tu fait pas bon c'est 6 après des
patrouilles possible d'installer
mettront en place et s'étoffe c'est un
raffinement des masters series de sortir
du cross mener d'autres choses négatives
ou salés quelqu'un qui s'y connaît bien
aussi le ticket qui aurait pris le temps
d ouais
puis zz top et je pense que d'être bien
entouré ces cinq réussites ben non ça
pour ça simplement je suis changé la
chance d'être bien entouré d'un certain
si je mettais divo ajouté via soumah du
monde qui vont vouloir comme ça je ne
peux plus a dit pas moi puis comme un
nadal toujours un mois c'est sale et
laid
des vrais champions roussillon resté
pareil même avec moi je suis content de
voir son papa de papa d'et comme le
trimestre et que c'est pour ça aussi on
en parle même pour la cia
mais oui maison c'est cool mais ça c'est
fait je me sens comme si je me sens pas
comme dépayser ou je suis petit je
n'arrête pas de dire je suis super à
l'aise c'est votre premier le métro
puisse pas reconnaître dans la rue ça
c'est une chose mais le fait quelqu'un
de savoir que malgré tout qu'est ce que
tu viens de vivre teacher me perçois de
la mamma mia qui était vu le trou au
mois passé encore plus haute mais oui
c'est encore plus mais j'ai ma couille
merci beaucoup mais ça me fait plaisir